[Music]
good morning John it's Monday January
29th and I'm standing on top of little
Pisgah mountain just like you are dead
and sister that I use this plane clip in
the video I don't know why I actually
filmed that video three days ago but you
have no way of knowing that
how's that for movie magic so it's three
days later now and we've done the jump
to Athens and I'm at a friend's house
we've been having a good time in Athens
it's pretty nice city I suggest you try
it on sometime the today's video is a
short video because last night my
friends and I spent quite a long time
creating a project that I would like to
share with you as it is inspired by you
as an added bonus you will get to see my
wife Katherine apparently she's not
quite the Yeti that your wife is and
will occasionally come out in public
also you may notice featured in this
video Brian noose and Jesslyn shields
two of my best friends who live here in
Athens and assisted me with this project
a very great deal will you miss me when
I'm gone from your pants will you miss
me when I'm gone from your pants will
you miss me when I'm gone gone gone will
you miss me when I'm gone from your head
I bounced around Jimmy
yeah
you miss me when I'm gone romance
[Music]
with you miss me when I'm gone
that's all there you have it I'll see
you tomorrow you know how some DVDs have
bonus features well Brotherhood 2.0 has
bonus features too and you're about to
see one you might expect that blue you
miss me when I'm gone from your pants
took more than one take to film it did
here's the first take miss me